"Kaakon kulmalta", tämmönen mummeli,
"eikö tuota, on Seiska lehdessä, lukioilla ja kuvaajilla riitä mitä muan huomoritajuja,
tai muutaku, lukioiden hauskat kuva, elukoita, elukoita, missä vene, se aina elukoita, laittakaa jotain hauskempaa, hei."
Seiskan toimitukselle on terveiset lähetetty, pientä hienosäätöä siihen lehteen kaipaa, yksi lukija.
Se on Kansanradio ja Lasse Olki nuoretessa tervehdys.
Hienosäätöä, tai sitten sellaista suursäätöä, niinkuin myös tässä tulevan jakson aikana tullaan kuulemaan.
Esimerkiksi, eteläsuomalaisille kerrotaan, että voisivat pysyä poissa Pohjois-Suomesta, kun eivät osaa käyttäytyä.
Kouluruokaa oppisi kuulema juniorit arvostamaan, jos tietäisivät, minkälaista se on joskus ennen ollut.
Ja kalsarit nousevat puheenaiheeksi, muun muassa sen takia, kun niistä ei kuulema, ihan kaikkialla pitäisi puhua.
No hei, täällä yks veitikka tuota. Kuunteni tuosta Ylä-Suomen radiolähetystä, ja teillä näköjään puhutaan miesten kalsareiden vaihdostakin, sunnuntai puheitani.
Eikö se mei vähä, liian alas, että puhutaan miesten kalsarivaihtopäivistä ja dillosista.
Eikö täällä muuta puhumista sija osia ylelle? Tällaista veitittoa asioa?
Okei, moi.
No, tästä lähtee. Mitä mainostetaan? Onko tuote vai alaston ihminen mainoksessa se tärkein seikka?
Meillä on nyt tuolla televisiossa näkyily muutamia mainoksia, joissa on alastomiamiehiä,
Nyks on menossa jääkaapile riisuu housunsa, ni mitäpä siinä nyt sitten mainostetaan?
Kyllä tätä mainostusta on todella niin paljon, että toivottavasti niistä tulee hiukan asiallisempia, eikä näitä alastomia ihmisiä siellä näy. Kiitos. Hei.
Pörssisähköyhtiö kerääny Hannes Myrskyn tappioota pörssisähkön käyttäjiltä.
On kuulemma mukajouduttu tuulivoimalat pirättämähän kuon siivet jää.
"Voi, kessa, kusi, eikä näynyt muuta keksin, kiitos."
"Tässä niin, Merkki, äly, hoi, huutelee älympärää.
Kysin vaan, että ootteko nähny oikee viisasta miestä?
Nykyaikana, kun käypi viisasta kuka tahansa.
"Minäpä kerron, kun se viisas mies Einstein oli jo kauan sitten sanonut, että kun tieto lisääntyy, niin ihminen tyyt menee.
"Tässä me ollaan."
"Nyt minä sanon, jotta heittäkää hyvät ihmiset ne älyväkyttimet ois, ja käyttäkää omia aivoja.
Luoja antoi meille aivot käytettäviksi, ihan niinkuin hauviksetkin pulisteltaviksi, että älyn heräämistä vaan kansalle, toivottaa.
Äly, hoi.
"Kansaradio."
"Täällä yks Mutsikin kuuntelija, ja mulla ihan muutama sana sanottavana."
"Kerro."
"Kyllä minä ni oon mieleni pahottanu, ja musiikikorva kärsinnää, kun vanhoista hyvistä kappaleista muokattaa, jos jommiin moisia vinkumisia ja uillutuksia, jopa joululauluista.
"Eikö nykyisyyä musiikin tekijöillä, jotka haluavat lauleta? On mitään tekstin tuottamistaitoja, omia sanotuksia. Jos ei taito riitä, niin ei niitä vanahojakkaa kannata rueta muuttelen, ihan kauheiksi uusiksi kappaleiksi.
"Mietipä esimerkiksi sitä, kuunteli yks päivä suklaasydän, hyvää vanaho kappale. Ni aivan kamala uusi versio.
"Eli kaikki kunniaa näille, jotka näitä tehtyö, mutta pikku se ajattelua mukkaan, että käyttäkää omaa ajattelutaitoa ja tehkee omia sanotuksia, niitä on sivu moalimman tehty, niin mikä se nyt tämä uusi versio on?"Nii.
Täipä, mulla tästä muuta kuule, ku kauhean mukaisi kevään tulloa, outan täällä ja sinne kansa oikein hyvää musiikin soittoa.
Minä kiitän, mutta saako kysyä kysymyksen ennen kuin päästet menemään?
Entä jos tuolla on jossain ulkona ihminen, joka on kuunnellut tästä suklaasydämestä sen uuden version ja sen jälkeen vasta kuullut sen alkuperäisen ja tuumi, että eipä se alkuperäinen kyllä on mistään kotoisin, kiva on tää uusi versio.
Niinpä, meillä on monta mieltä, mutta se, että miten se tehdään, se uusi versio, niin minä oon ihan taatusti sitä mieltä, että joka on Vanaha-versioon tykännyt, niin minä luulen, että se on niinkuin tälle meidän ikäisille kansalle ihan hyvä.
Ja toki, en Sanoppa halasi tästä uuttakkaan versio, vaan oli se kauhean kuulona.
Kaikki kunniaisille, laulajalle ja tekijälle, ja toivottavasti ideaa riittää näillä nuorilla uusilla kykyillä.
Kiitos sinulle kuulemisesta ja hyveä kevättä.
Kiitos, sitä samaa.
Kiitos.
Kiitos, moi.
Nimimerkki Pettynyt Katsoja on laittanut meille kirjeenkoskien kaksi viikkoa sitten järjestettyä kultainen Venla Gaalaa.
Kysyy kirjeensä alussa, että minne on suomalaisilta naisilta hävinnyt tyylitaju.
Juhla iltaan tullaan asusteissa, jotka näyttävät lähinnä joulukuusen koristeelta, juontajat mukaan lukien.
Eivät taineet ymmärtää, että on juhlatilaisuus kyseessä, eikä lasten ohjelma.
PS, toki siellä niitä kauniitakin, pukuja oli.
Tällaisen viestin kaksi viikkoa sitten järjestetystä tapahtumasta laittoi siis Pettynyt Katsoja.
Seuraavat soittajat puolestaan kommentoivat viime viikon tapahtumia.
Täällä yksi veronmaksaja, mikä maksaa yleveroa.
Ja kyllä minä ihmettelen, että minä maksan yleveroa jostain tämän illan aatolkista.
Ei vois vähemmän kiinnostaa joku tuppuraisen sanominen, se ei oo mikään yleisradion aihe.
Täällä jahdetaan aina ihmisiä, kelantärkyperse muijat, ei voinu sietää, kun johtaja sanoi, että yks päivä kuusa tehdään oikein lähityötä.
Kun Peppua loukattu kulkas, kun on pikkuisen sanottu tiukemmalla äänellä, etkö sinä nyt niinkun ymmärä asiaa, eippa perjantai viäköön.
Tervettältä ylemmiltä vesiltä.
Semmosta vaan kuule, että miksi rupesitte vainumaan tätä meidän entistä ministeriä, nykyistä kansaedustajaa, Oulusta lähtösi oleva tytti tuppurasta siellä eduskunnassa.
Mukaahan olisi jollekin sanonut liian pahasti ja jotakin, ynnää muuta, ynnää muuta.
No totta, hyvän aikakohan o eduskuntaryhmän puheenjohtaja, ni pitää hänellä komentaa sitä porukkaa, sanoa asioita, kuulkaa, jos ne eivät ymmärrä ja niin poispäni.
Tee vaan näitä meitä pohjassuomalaisia vainuatta siellä Helsingin päässä, mutta miksi te tulette tänne hörhöt, etelä hörhöt, kauheilla miljardeilla rahoilla meidän Pohjassome vallottamaan ja tänne hiihtokeskukseen laskettelemään ja juopottelemaan, paikalliset saakkuille.
Eihän siellä on meillä mitää sijää, kun etelä hörhöt ottaa vallannu kaiken.Nyt ooke, aa, talkissa oli tästä tuppurasta jutteli, hävettää etelä sovolase, pas, kiitos ja heippa.
Niile, kun on suora sähkö, lämmitys, on tosi ankeat ajat. Pörsisähkö on nyt niin kallista.
Aina iltaisin, kun ihmiset tulevat töistä kotiin laittamaan ruokaa, tiskikonetta päälle, ja kulutus on korkein.
Onko se taktikointia vai ihan oikeaa aitoa tattumaa, että juuri illan tunnit ovat kalleinta?
Kysyn vaan, vaikken vastausta herroita saa, yks normikuluttaja.
Lasten määrä tippuja, syntyvyys on raskussa, ja monet on tästä tosi huolissaan, ihan ymmärrettävästi Suomesta.
Mä olen pienen vaivan äiti, ja oon miettinyt kovasti, et miten me voitaisi tukea perheitä, koska tuntuu, et monet nuoret nykyään pelkääki sitä, et minkälaista vauva arki on, eikä se ainakaan kannusta tohon syntyvyyden nostamiseen.
Mun mielestä syntyvyys saataisiin kasvoon sillala, et tuetaan lapsiperheitä entistä enemmän, ihan toinen toisiaamme tukien.
Meidän olis hyvä puhua vauvoista ja lapsiarjeesta kannustavasti, ja tuoda esiin myönteisiä asioita, myös myönteisiä asioita vanhemmuudesta.
Lapset on ihmeellisiä, ja vanhemmuus on oikeasti tosi iso lahja, ja tähän me halutaan kannustaa.
Vanhempia kuitenkin tarvitsi tukea yhä enemmän, jotenkin uusia vanhempia, koska monillanne, esimerkiksi iso vanhemmat on töissä, ei oo enää samalla tavalla kyläisteisellä tukemassa lapsen kasvattamisessa, ei ihme, että monet uupuu.
Kannuttaa oikeasti kysyä lähipiirin vanhemmilta, et mitä kuuluu, voisiko auttaa jossakin?
Välillä kans kuulee sitä, että hirveesti paheksutaan sitä, jos lasten äänet kuuluu julkisilla paikoilla, vaikka ravintoloissa, taikka busseissa, mutta lasten äänethan kuuluu osa elämää.
Jos me halutaan syntyvyys nousua, niin sitten täytyy pikkuisen sietää lasten ääniä.
Ja sit sitä, että vanhemmat mokaa välillä, mut ei tarvii siäädä välttämättä taivastelemaan sitä, jos tuntemat on, tai tuttukin vanhempi tekee jotää vähän kummalista, et vanhemmuus on oppimista, ja ei yksittäisistä asioista kannata ketään syyllistää liikaa.
Ollaan armollisia, autetaan ja kannustetaan, ja tuetaan myös heitä, jolle lapsen saaminen ei oo kovinkaa helppoa.
Senttiä kaikille vauvoja vanhemmille, nimimerkki vauvan äiti.
Viime viikolla puolestaan täällä kansanradiossa kuuluista asioista on puhututtanut muun muassa koti- ja laitosoito.
Yksi aiheesta saapunut viesti menee näin.
Kansanradiossa nishenkilön mielestä apua tarvitsevat, voitaisiin laittaa laitoksiin vaihtoehtona kotona asumiselle, jotta vältettäisiin esimerkiksi turhat auttajien ajelut paikasta toiseen.
Sanonpa tälle ajattelijalle, että kukapa sitä kotoaan haluaa lähteä, jos apua voi saada vaikka vähänkin.
Mietipä sitä omalta kohdaltasi, jos tarve olisi.
Ystävälläni käy aamuun ja illoin kymmenen minuutin ajan avustaja, joka esimerkiksi antaa aamu- ja iltapalat ja pukee ja riisuu vaatteet.
Päivisin käy henkilökohtainen avustaja ruokaa lämmittäen, ja näillähän pärjää kotona, kun teen itse näitä töitä alustavasti valmiiksi viikonloppuisin.
On ikäihmisille ja parantumattomille mukavampaa.
Eipä kannata muutaman euron bensakuluja surra, terveisin, vielä näin jaksava ystävä.
Kansaradio.
Ensko aaretti Savosta tervee.
Oli oikein mielenkiintoinen kansaradio tänään, kiitoksia siitä sinne.
Korvini otti erityisesti, kun siellä joku sanoi, että politikkojen vastuun kanto.
Kolokompaa ministeritä, politikko, se on aina vaalipropagandaese, että kyllä he kantaa vastuun.
Ei ne kannaa mistään mitään vastuuta.
On hyvin vähän töitä, mitä ne on tehny, niinku on luvanneet.
Ei ole työllisyys asiat korjautunu, vanhuksia kivistettää taloudellisesti.
On siellä jotakin, mitä on tehty, onko ne sitä oikein tehty, kandais miettii.
Nii.
Ja toinen, mikä oli hirveen kiva juttu, niin tämä laulussa, että semmoisia olkipillipiipaloita, siellä vinkuu, nuoria naisia.
Ni minäkin haluaisin haastaa nykyiset laulun tekijät, säveltäjä, sanoittaja, tekemään sellaisia lauluja, kuin kuus, seitmän, 80-luvulla oli, että niissä on sanomaa, rytmiä.
Ja sitten, ei olisi sitä, että samoja asioita kerrataan sen kymmenen kertaan, sitten kerksissä perattään samaa, että olen ollut siellä, olen ollut täällä ja niipoispäin.
Ei, mitään muutaku, oikein hyvää talvenjatkoa sullekin ja kaikille, radion kuuntelijoille.
Minä toivotan hyvät päiväjatkot myös.
Kiitos.Kiitos.Moi.
Sulo, Esposta, ei. Tuossa puhuttiin äskenään kansareliossa, tuosta presidentin pukeutumisesta.
No, varmaan ihan muutaisen osin ok, mutta kyllähän sais sitä, vähän paremmin huolehtia, sitä solmion solmusta.
Se on aina vähän semmoinen kyseenalaiden. Ei muuta, kiitos, ei.
Eläkärouva täällä ihmettelee, äskeisen soittailan mukaan, aivan samaa mielipide on, eduskunnan pitkistä, pitkistä lomista on, minun mielestäni, outoa.
Maailma on aivan mullin malli, ja Suomessa asiat myöskin mullin mallin.
On väärin, että siellä lomaillaan, Kanarialla ja Alpeilla, ja loma jatkuu.
Elikkä nykyaikaistettava ja lyhennettävä on kyllä lomia. Ei muuta, kiitos.
Kohta kahdeksankymppinen, mummeli soittelee, olen aivan samaa mieltä, että kirosanat pois lauluista, se on ihan älytöntä.
Ei, kiitän ensinnäkin siitä, että siellä tulee niin paljon sellaisia mielipiteitä, mitä itsekin haluaisi esittää.
Ja tuo oli yks niistä, tämä tyttöjen, tyttöjen vikinäkulku on, ku joku pikku tytöt laulaisi, kaikki laulaisi samalla tavalla, semmoista merkillistä piiperystä.
Ja toinen, mikä tuota oli mielestäni, oli tämä, että, no, nyt tuli blackout, mutta se on yks kyllä, että kansanradio oli ihan kiva kuunnella, ku mielipiteet osuu hirveen paljon.
Yksi, ulotaan vaan, että nämä meidän kuulijat olis vähän monipuolisempi, että tämä päättäjätki joskus kuuntelis meidän mielipiteitä. Moikka.
Helmikuun pakkasten keskellä on kansanradion saapunut muun muassa seuraavanlainen viesti.
Työnantajan toimesta. Hoitajat värjettelevät pihalla pitkiäkin aikoja, kuka missäkin asussa, huomioliivit sentään on raskittu ostaa.
Helsingissä valtaa pitävissä on ollut pitkään NS-työntekijöiden puolella olevia päättäjiä, mutta tuntuu, että heillä on enemmän kiirettä rakennella pienelle eliitille siltoja, kuin pitää yhdestä tärkeimmistä työntekijöistään huolta.
Yhtenäinen ja asianmukainen vaatetus antaisi arvokkaamman kuvan työstä, ja kenties motivoisi työntekijöitä.
Viesti laittanut, nimimerkki, erään, lapsen, isä.
Eli Helsingissä tilanne tämä, minkälaisia muita huomioita, ja mistäkin päin Suomea tässä viikon aikana tullut, no, tehdäänpä seuraavaksi pienimuotoinen kierros.
Kolomen miljoonelöistä korvattiin näitä lähinnä maanvililöille, kun ne siellä Pohjanmaalla, niitä on satoja tuhansia, ne syödä kaikki pellot puhtaaksi.
Mut se, mitä ne tekee suuriskaupunkissa, on hirveä onkelma.
Esimäksi Turussa, nätti Ruissaloranta.
Ei niihin voi mennä, me oltiin vepsässä perheen kans.
Aivan täynnä valkoposkihania, ja ulosteita, koko siakkarata täynnä.
Ja sama Ruissalossa.
Ja joku EU kieltää niiden metsästyksen.
Mun mielestä siinä pitää nyt Suomen valtion olla piukkana.
Et annetaan lupia metsästä, et saadaan sillä, et ihmiset voi olla niinko, sää hiakkaran olla rauhasatta, ettei tarvitse kattoo, mihin astu, et onko siinä nyt sitten hanhen ulosteita tai ei.
Toivottavasti jotain järkeä tulee tähän hommaan, ei muuta.
No hei, täällä eläkeläinen Jyväskylästä.
Ihmettelin tuota, ku iltasanomassa luin, että Suomi työntää milianteja ja milianteja sinne Afrikan kehitysapuun, et nehän joka maille annetaan hirveet kosat rahaa, ja tota, eihän ne mene sinne, minne on tarkoitettu.
Ja eliitin taskuu mene, koko kehitysapu pitäis lopettaa, omat köyhet täällä kärvistellä.
Ei nämä meidän politikot auta omaa kansaa, mutta sinne kyllä työnnetää rahaa Lapiolla kaupalla.
Näin on, ja Ukrainaa.
No ei mulla muuta, sui armittaa vaan.
No, moi.
No joo, se oi Jussi täältä Pohjanmaalta.
Ihmettelen meidän yrivoimalaitoksille.
Mitä meidän yrivoimalaitoksille kuuluu?
Onko sauappalainen loppuu?
Huonosti on uutisoitu.
Tuulivoimalootteen lavatoi jääs, sähköhinta pililis.
Ei koskaan ollut pörsisähkönään korkialle, jotta voi perkelele, ei muuta.
No nii, täältä syrkankylästä originaalihyvää päivää.
Auraavat näitä liittymiä.
Puoli maantietaurathan aina liittyvään, eikä sitä kukhaa, sitä potsaa, mukkunamät, teläkiläiset vanhat ihmiset.
Vähillä voimilla, niin jos tämän ohelman kautta sais päätteille tietoa, niin olis hyvää.
Koska vanhemmat ihmiset, tuomanen jäinen lastu, mikä siihen auratyöntää kymmeniä kymmeniä kertoja vuodossa, niin se alkaa voimat vähenemään, ja sitä ei oikein mihin sitä siinä aina laittaa.
Tielaitahan ei saa pukata, siitä on kunnanmiehet käyny erikseen kieltämässä, että siihen ei saa panna, että auramiesten kalusto särkyy ja menee huonoksi, niin se on täysin kielletty.
Olen tietoinen, että esimerkiksi Etelä-Suomessa monin paikoin auroissa on niin sanottu kaappa, millä ne sieppaa siitä liittymän kohalta sen lumen ja jään matka, ja vapauttavat sen sinne oihan, ku pääsevät liittymään ohi.
Miks ei täällä pohjoisessa semmoista ole, ku täällä tätä lunta saattaa olla jopa metrin verran keväälläni? Täällä se kaappa olis tervittäiset saatais nuo liittymä puhtaksi.
Toivon, että tähän kuulis semmoiset päätteet, joilla olis kykyä vaikuttaa näihin asioon. Kiitoksia, hei.
Kansanradiotervehdys.
No terve täällä, Sirkka Liisa.
Joo, mä valitan siitä, että mun sepustukset ei siellä oo kuulunu.
Sun sepustukset ei oo täällä kuulunu.
Nyt kyllä kuuntelen, kerro vaan, että mistä aiheesta oot soittanut, tai mistä haluat kaikkeen eniten puhuu.
Joo, mä oon soittanut monesta aiheesta, mutta mä tuon vaan yhen aiheen nyt.
Nykypäiväruoka on siihen verrattuna, kun juhla illallinen, sanon paha vaan.
Koululaisten ruoka tarkoitan.
Sanon vielä, että se oli maalaiskouluja.
Meillä oli semmoinen ruoka, et my oltiin tota kerätty syksylä puolukoita.
Ja?
Ja ne piti viedä sinne koululle.
Siehen laitettiin sitten keittejä laitto, jotain ryyniä ja jotain mitäliä laittanu, ja sitten sitä puolukkaa.
Ja sitten hän laittoi semmoiseen vanhaa aikaa, oli semmoisia emalikuppeja, mistä syöttiin.
Ja.
Ni hän laittoi pohjalle semmoisen lötkyn sitä, ja tuota, se oli se lötky vissi monta tuntia siinä, et se oli ihan kylmää.
Yksi ainut oppilas siinä, niin se söi sen.
Ja myös sitten mentii rivissä taas, ja vietii ruuvat siihen, ja laitettiii semmoiseen isoon muovisaaviin.
Ja kiitettiii, ja mä ajattelin nyt jälkeenpäin, jotta tuota, minkä takia piti oikeastaan hakekaa sitä, ku he ei voinu syödä.
Nii. Mitenköhän menis tänä päivänä koulussa läpi tuollainen ruoka?
No ei varmaan, kun ei, ei tuota, kun ne käy, niitä epäterveellisiä ruokia sieltä ostamassa monetki.
Et tämmöne, että terveisiä kaikille, jos joku kuuntelee, lietää tää jutun.
Kansanradion whatsappista puolestaan löytyy Kerimäeltä saapunut viesti.
Luomumies Kerimäeltä kaipaa mäkihyppyyn perinteistä kankkosnykästyyliä nykyisen harakkatyylin rinnalle,
joko omana kilpailuna tai toinen hyppy nykyisellä ja toinen perinteisellä.
Onhan hiidossakin perinteinen ja luistelutyyli.
Siinä siis Kerimäeltä sellainen toivomus, toivomus, josta siirrytään seuraavanlaisiin kysymyksiin,
että on ihmisillä sitten pähkältävää ja vastattavaa.
Koposimallia 48, hyvää päivää.
Pelinen pakko ottaa kantaa tähän armeijan touhuun.
Nuoret miehet, jotka lähtivät Tammiku alussa Pohjoiseen armeijan,
eikö ole mitään niin saattiva pakkasrajaa, noin 40 asteen pakkasta ja hiihtolenkille,
noin niinkuin pystyssä vaan.
Kokemattomat nuoret miehet onhan pakkasrajat urheilioillakin.
Armeijan alussa vakavia sairastumisia, esimerkiksi keukko kuume,
eikö tämmöisiin keleihin voisi järkätä vaikka teoriatuntia?
Mitä hyötyä on, kun nuoret miehet sairastuu?
Eipä ole kohta kouluttettavia.
Nyt varmaan joku sanoo, että jos on sotatila, täytyy mennä ilmalla ku ilmalla.
Mutta miten mennään, kun jo nuorena sairastutaan miehet?
Pohrastakaa jotenkin tätä alkua, että ei ihan alussa noin rankkaa.
Eikö mikään ole muuttun tuolesta 6668?
Jotain inhimillisyyttä?
Onko vieläkin kouluttajissa tämmöisiä hörhöjä suoraa?
Sano, että katotaanpa miten pojat kestää.
Järkikä teen tästäkin asiasta?
Toivoo, mummo.
Hei.
No nii.
Nää ihmettelee, että ku tuommoiset miehet oo irrallaan, ku tulla naapuriseakin,
ne saa tehdä tuansia murhia.
Ja tuota, toi ne on ylä, tulla rapaton toosella puurella.
Ja, ku meikälä ne, jos tekee yhen murhan, ni istuu vankilasa ilman muu.
Ja mihinkähän se, tämä maailma on mennyt?
Nääkin oo eläni jo yli 90 vuotta, ja tuota, en oo vielä murhaa tehäni,
ja nämä saa tehdä tuansia.
Semmonee vaan, muistutus, että eikä näillä oo mitään vastuun.
Morjes.
Hyvä kansanradio, täällä puhuu maalaismuori.
Kuinka voi olla Suomi onnellisin maa, kun täällä eriarvoisuus niin kukoistaa?
Ei ole työtä kaikille antaa, vaikka kuinka pätevä ja koulutettu olisit.
Sitten tulee vastaan ikä.
Ja, jos olet vaikka 55 vuotta täyttänyt, olet yleensä jo liian iäkäs.
Mutta, mites on mahdollista, että kansanedustajaksi pääsee 70-vuotias, kun sattuu olemaan se oikea puolue, kokoumus?
Siks kysynkin, onko eduskunnassa yläikä rajaa, ja koska sieltä pääsee eläkkeelle? Kiitos, ja hei.
Huomenta, kansanradio.
Nyt on se viherpiipeltä jään ennustama.
Lämmenyt talvi, ilmasto lämpenee.
Nehän vihervasemmastolaiset jankuttaa koko ajan, kuinka ilmasto lämpenee, jäävuoret, sula ja kaikki.
Kuinkaan ne lämpenee nyt, kun on tällainen 20-25 astetta, pakkasta.
Se on vain sellainen keksitty juttu.
Jot palaa ihmiset maksamaan kaikesta, ylimäärässä se turhasta.
Mitä louhotetaan, että ilmasto lämpenee.
Lämpimiä kausia on ollut aina kautta aikoja, pilmiä kausia, nyt on oten kunnollinen vanhan ajan talvi.
Et mitäs viherpiipertää nyt sanoo? Ei mitää muuta.
Tähän loppuun kuullaan vielä vähän viikon aikana saapuneita ehdotuksia, että mitä tästä maasta puuttuu, tai mitä on vähän liikaa, ja sehän on sitten sen jälkeen kansanradiopaketissa.
Ennen niitä ehdotuksia kerron yhteystiedot, että minne voi halutessaan ehdottaa, jos siis ehdotuttaa.
Meidän whatsapp-numerossa on 044 55 154 64, siihen vaan viestiä, äänitse tai tekstiteen.
Kirjettä tai postikorttia, jos haluaa lähettää, niin:
Kansanradio, PL 799 000 24, Yleisradio.
Sähköposti meinasi melkein unohtua, se on kansan.radio@yle.fi.
Ja meidän vastaajan numero 0800 154 64.
Lasse Olkunuora toivottaa hyvää päivänjatkoa ja hyvää vointia.
Ei, en tiedä, onko tässä vaiheessa vuotta muuten vielä tapana ilakoida sitä, että kohta on kevät, mutta kyllä minä nii nyt aion joka tapauksessa tehdä.
Ei muuta kuin kevättä kohden.
Tää on täältä etelä saa vuosta kuuskymppinen ukko, ehottaa sille porolle tuota, tuommoista yrittäjää palakintoa.
Nyt se ruppee, tuota, vanahusimmiset vähennemään, tuota, Suomen muista ku hoitajia vähennettää.
Ja Orpo tulluu tosina hyvänä kakkosina ku hoitolaitoksia vähennettää, niin, tuota, kyllä, kyllä Pies Ura ja Orpo, niin, tuota, vanahusista tulaviissii errotta.
E, ku, vaan kummalekki yrittäjää palakintoja saavat niitä tunnin ratoja rakennettua sitä hoitajien palakoille.
Kyt, eipä tässä tää on kummempia.
No, raili täällä Marttilasta tervehdys. Ajattelin puhua tästä lentoliikenteestä.
Kun on tämmöset halpalennot meneillään, karikymppi vaan maksaa lento, niin eikä niissä oo minkälaista haittaveroa.
Eli se on ehdottomasti hyvin tärkeää, et olis edes haittavero, kun se saastuttaa niin paljon.
Olen sitä ihmetellyt, kun ei edes vihreät ole puuttuneet siihen, vaikka, mun mielestäni, se kuuluisi erikoisesti heille, tämä haittaveron ehdottamis.
Perussuomalaisten purra ilmoitti, että puolueen varallisuus on mennyt yli kahren miljoonan, ja he ovat sijoittaneet kultaan, joka on tuplaantunut arvoltansa.
Ihmettelen kyllä, jotta puoluetuki esimerkiksi, niin se ei oo tarkoitettu sijoitettavaksi.
Se on vermaksajien rahaa, ja se ei oo tarkoitettu sijoitettavaksi, vaan käytettäväksi vuosittaisin puolueen ylläpitoa ja toimintahan.
Siiis, ymmärtääkseni, he eivät tarvitsisi mitään puoluetukia.
Pois puoluet tuet tuolaisilta, jolla on tuolainen varallisuus.
Täällä puhuu marjottamummo Pohjois-Karjalasta.
Vanhenpani opettivat, ketään ei tarvitse pelätä, kunnioittaa tai arvostaa sen vuoksi,
Että heillä on niin sanottua maalista varallisuutta, arvoasemaa, lukeneisuutta tai mitään elittisyyttä.
Nä, että kaikki ihmiset ovat samanarvoisia.
Mutta, mutta…
Velleni vaimo oli keksinyt paremman, hän sanoo olevansa luontainen jännittäjä oudossa seurassa.
Silloin hän ajattelee tämän ihmisen istumassa:
Vessäpytyllä, varmasti alkaa hymyilyttää, siis koko Suomen kansa.
Jos tulee liikaa kunnioituksen tunteita, tämä ohje on vapaasti käytettävissä.
Ajatelkaa esimerkiksi Trumpia, Putinia, Stuppia, Häkkästä, Purraa, Orpoa, Marirantasta
ja kaikkia maailman mahtavia ja tärkeitä kyseiseen tilanteeseen hoosutkintuissa istumassa veseypytyllä.
Ne eivät siis eroa millään tavalla mistään perustarpeista kuin kukaan maailman syntyneitä ihmisistä.
Sis hyvää ja hauskaa jatkoa elämälle. Heippa!